and that rampage comes during a wave of
nationwide attacks
targeting asian americans research from
stop aapi h shows nearly 3 800 incidents
were reported over the course of
roughly a year during the pandemic i
spoke with members of our local asian
american community tonight
to see how they're handling all of this
my first reaction was
you know oh my god is this all targeting
all asian
lea yulianti shares the moment she heard
about tuesday's shooting in atlanta
that's very unfortunate and sad eight
people were killed
including six women of asian descent
this comes amid a startling rise
in asian related racism across the
country the safety
is very important for us as a business
owner in southern nevada
yulianti says stories like this spark
real fear for the future
although it was very shocking it was
outrage
but it wasn't surprising just by the
rise of the hate
eric jang of the asian community
development council calls this a serious
issue
a new report by csu san bernardino found
a 150 percent
surge in asian hate crimes across the
nation in the last year
jang says the main ways to fight it are
more education
and a real change in rhetoric so we're
calling not just for
our community to protect ourselves but
also for the solidarity
that's why he and juliante are asking
those in las vegas to come together
and stand behind anyone who's struggling
i think
everybody needs to stop looking at each
other based on
their race you know and start looking at
one another
as a human being with a value
the asian community development council
encouraged any member
of our local asian american community
who needs help with attacks rooted in
racism to reach out to them
we have their contact information on our
website 8newsnow.com